c'est de la survie il n'y a pas de place pour les nouvelles
ce jeu vidéo régit votre vie de slobs
jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'au championnat du cyber
Bowl ici à Los Angeles
quand vous voulez tellement gagner que vous pouvez le
goûter le sentir
et le tuer
mais pour vivre le rêve votre vie le fera
ça ne fait qu'empirer si tu ne maîtrises pas
tes problèmes de colère j'ai l'impression que j'avais besoin
d'entendre ça tu dois devenir ta
fille c'est incroyable
le cauchemar de quelqu'un ça va
c'est un compte à rebours pour l'extase je suis désolé je
ne peux pas t'entendre mon  les grenadiers
peuvent la meilleure victoire nue voir les nouvelles obtenir votre
visage de jeu